Oh everyone how's everyone doing today
open you're doing as well as I am today
I'd like to review the kfj the public
space debate we had the other day with
Peter and we talked about black holes
there's a little bit of problems with
some of the things that were said maybe
everything wasn't clarified and I'd like
to and clarify those things today
anyways first I want to make sure that I
cover what another subject which is you
know Boris where you have this
conference in June and there's been a
little bit of an update that's on the
8th of June Saturday that's when the
that's when our conference is going to
take place so that's 8th of June in or a
Sweden ok it's little town there right
between somewhere between Copenhagen in
Denmark and Stockholm in Sweden so you
can find it out of math Boris you are a
SDA with the angstrom little sign on it
hey Boris I hope I'm pronouncing that
well I'm sure our host over there is
gonna correct me on that let's see it
right ok so what's the deal with black
holes or what we did well you know let's
start with what happened on Sunday I had
a little debate and it was with Peter
again he is a mathematical physicist he
teaches at a university and he's
primarily a quantum guy he does research
for what I can tell in the realm of
quantum he's not specifically geared
towards general relativity
so we can excuse him on that count you
know not everybody's an expert in every
field just because someone is a
mathematical physicist doesn't mean that
he knows all of it okay he does have a
general understanding of each of the
fields but he specializes in quantum and
jfg there you have him smiling as always
with his French accent carries his
program called the public space and he
brings us every now and then to discuss
some of these things things such as what
we talked about the other day which is
black holes and dark matter I'd like to
concentrate a little bit on the dark
matter side I'm sorry in the black hole
side not so much under a dark matter I
think the dark matter since she has the
same thing and in general terms my my
view on this is that both dark matter
and black holes are conveniently
invisible conveniently heavy and they're
both just for people so that they know
for a fact what's going on they're just
variables in an equation that's all they
are they represent mass runaway mass
lots of mass in a small area small
region small volume or no volume in the
case of black holes but the idea is that
there's a lot of mass in a very small
region and why did it have to do that
because that was the only way they could
explain some of the phenomena that they
were of the astronomers were observing
out there one of them was that stars
we're going around around nothing
they were orbiting a center and there
was nothing in that center and they were
going kind of fast like several one I
measured one of those to be 40
was it the yeah I think was 45,000
kilometers and it was doing it in 5.6
days that's cygnus x-1 and they said you
know what is this thing orbiting around
and other stars they noticed that
they're losing gas you know like they're
gasses skin and it was going into
nowhere it was just losing something was
dragging us this gas from the skin of
the star and it was going off into
nowhere so uh black hole dark matter
same thing they couldn't figure it out
why the galaxy rotated as no bicycle
wheel as a carousel you know everything
at the same time or like I like to say
the buggies on the outside just as fast
as the horse is on the inside you know
if if everything is kind of fluid then
the horses should go first and you know
the buggy should trail behind as the
carousel twirls just like Pluto Pluto
falls behind mercury mercury goes around
in the Sun in 88 days Earth days and
Pluto takes 248 years to go around the
Sun so it lags it falls way behind
that's not the case with stars on the
outside of almost any galaxy stars on
the outside of a galaxy travel just as
fast or faster than the ones on the
inside
they keep pace you know all the room as
the galaxy goes around so would it
suggest to you is that you know the
whole galaxy rotates as a wheel okay it
rotates as a single entity that's that's
the notion that you got to get from this
okay we got some hi Pedro hello let me
adjust this thing yeah
okay I guess I can't get it to adjust
completely I don't know why okay anyways
so so that's where they got these
notions that's where they've got the
notion of the black hole that's where
they got the notion of Dark Matter they
just had to put a lot of like I say a
lot of kilograms they put a lot of
kilograms in certain regions to produce
the effects that they were observing
they had no other way to explain this
except saying you know we have runaway
mass so you know that this is what the
issue is the issue is that you know they
have to invent this variable in one case
a variable called black hole the other
one Oh a variable called dark matter
what's the problem the general problem
they're both convenient in the invisible
and they're conveniently very heavy to
satisfy the equations necessary to
produce those effects well you know I do
it a little differently I'm saying that
everything's interconnected and as far
as dark matter is concerned you can see
that right away that if everything is
connected
of course it rotates as a single
platform it rotates like a bicycle wheel
rotates like carousel like a
merry-go-round okay and that's the main
point there but I want to talk about
some other little a troublesome issue
that popped up the other day in in the
talks with Peter and jfg JMT came up and
he started his his show with a following
he started to show with this little
picture there right the pictures that he
started with was is the one on the left
the blue ones right there okay and so
what was the deal he said like you know
the Sun weighs down the canvas of
space-time anyway since it's got some
somewhat you know so much mass it'll do
that little curving in the canvas in the
what is in the fabric the fabric of
space-time if you take a neutron star
well it'll bend it a little more in
other words you don't take it down
further and if you have a black hole
it'll just you know take it all the way
down where he pronounced okay and his
image is the one you find on the
Internet here I have the ones on the
right those are the ones that I put in
there and you can see that he's pretty
much right that's the way people
visualize this thing you see those cones
with flat tops on the two top ones on
the right and then on the bottom what
you see is the famous discovery that two
black holes rotate around each other and
they create these gravitational waves
those gravitational ways were allegedly
discovered by the team from LIGO and a
couple years ago I think February 2016
and what happened well they got a Nobel
Prize for discovering that because they
they kind of killed two birds with one
stone they found not only that you know
not found but they confirmed all they
proved for the second time at least that
there are in fact black holes because
what else could go as gravity waves come
from except the collision of two black
holes like a billion years ago and they
also proved the gravity waves so they
killed two birds with one stone daily
they showed that black holes exist you
know because what else could have
created those waves except the collision
of
black holes it had to be two massive
objects they didn't see the mass of
objects this is an extrapolation this is
an inference they made the assumption
but they call those things proofs in
mathematical physics they say we proven
it they've proven that black holes are
there you can you know what else could
have caused it and then they proved the
gravity waves which had been predicted
by Einstein allegedly right and first we
need to clarify that I said did not
believe in gravity waves like he didn't
believe in black holes and he didn't
believe in Big Bang okay
people like to use the word Einstein
because they can get their point across
he said hey I said so oh if Einstein
said so who's gonna criticize them
here's here's Einstein's 2018 absurd
1918 paper hundred years ago and this is
his it was printed in a German journal
over gravitations okay and he he had
this published in 1918 and in it he
argued that gravitational waves are
nonsense he later wrote another Pope I'm
not sure he wrote a paper or formal
paper but I think he did but I'm not so
sure about that about 1935 1936 about
the time he was fighting with with the
quantum cope with Niels Bohr criticizing
quantum saying you know God does not
play dice that kind of thing and he
criticized again the gravitational waves
he says no such thing he didn't believe
in gravitational waves but people today
say oh yeah thanks time saying you know
we have black holes we have
gravitational waves we have big bang
I intend didn't believe in any other he
wrote papers against those ideas but
today they use a you know Einstein's
name to back on the basis of authority
you know they use it to back their ideas
anyways uh
so you know gravitational waves and here
here you have a Jif that shows you know
the two black holes rotating around each
other they get closer and closer and
closer until they collide when they
collide they generate gravity waves that
extend all the way to earth okay so this
is the notion that you're supposed to
see these gravity waves that come they
are created from the collision of two
black holes okay and I think it's pretty
straightforward the illustration there
okay okay so we have these two balls or
holes they run around each other they
collide they create way as waves come
all the way to earth straightforward
right okay
and Peter presented a scenario which is
not identical in sub quantum thing it's
got something nothing to do with with
gravity waves or with black holes but
it's got to do with waves and that's
what I want to talk about today here's
here's his scenario he says look if you
put oil and he didn't do the experiment
but he just referenced it and he says if
you put oil in this little that blue
part of the picture is the oil and you
have a shaker chase that whole
contraption and you'll see that little
dot a little blue dot there and that
little blue dot
you know jumps on the surface of that
blue oil and you can see the little
waves on the surface there and the blue
dot not only goes up and down jumping on
that surface but it also moves across
and it also does entanglement in other
words it does what the two black holes
just did run around each other and and
affect each other from a distance and
this is more or less what it looks like
okay here you have the oil drop just
moving across the surface also rolling
around each other called
tangle meant you have jumping on the oil
the oil drop jumping on the lake of oil
and all this because it's they're
creating a vibration from underneath you
know on the tank where the oil is and
they do all these fancy things and they
are able to film this with high-speed
camera so that they can see exactly
what's more or less what's happening
okay
and you can see this resembles in some
way to some degree what the two black
holes did when a year I'll show one more
time the black holes rotate okay and
they create gravity waves well the oil
drops create the waves which in turn you
know have a symbiotic relation and
affect the oil drops okay straight
forward more less okay so there is a
common a common theme here and the theme
that I want to get to has to do with
waves and let's see if I can well first
let me just get rid of the black hole
just off the bat so that you you are
convinced that black holes have no place
in science let alone in physics okay
bike holes are nonsense 100% nonsense
and the main reason here it is it's the
argument I like to start with that's uh
the black hole has never been defined no
one has any idea what a black hole is
that's that's the first issue and
specifically they can't tell you not a
single mathematician on earth can tell
you will ever tell you because the day
they do you know their their whole
theory goes down the drain they cannot
tell you whether a black hole is a black
ball or it collapses down to nothing and
becomes a region a hole in space-time it
kind of rips
spacetime open and becomes a little hole
entrance to space-time if you can
imagine that it's it's kind of surreal
istic but this is what they're trying to
convey to you so the question is whether
you can tell the difference between a
ball and a halt and you know many
mathematicians you know they went to
college but they they skip kindergarten
so they can't tell the difference
between a ball and a hole and you can't
really you know put this against them
not everybody is as fortunate as you but
to kindergarten but you know I would
like all the mathematicians to look at
this Bugs Bunny picture here bugs can
tell them what the difference between a
hole and a ball is the hole is into
something else in this case the ground
and ball is a standalone object that he
has in his hands in his hand right so
there's a difference between a ball and
a hole they're both round but what is
round three dimensionally the other one
is round two dimensionally when is an
entrance to something else the other one
is a standalone object then we can go on
and on with the differences between them
you'll just have to go to kindergarten
to figure out you know what the
differences are between a ball and a
hole and the mathematicians cannot tell
you whether a black hole looks like the
guy on the left or the guy on the right
is it like a ball or is it like a hole
that's the issue okay and I hopefully
you know most people can tell the
difference between them but not
everybody can apparently you know so
what can I say okay so that's the first
issue the other issue is that the black
hole is supposed to do this through
masse supposed to affect things at a
distance through mass and that's a
problem because in in the case of like I
just discussed about dark matter if all
the star
are if all the atoms in the universe are
interconnected by ropes extended ropes
that means all the stars are
interconnected by ropes I have a little
gift to simulate that and it looks like
this let's wait till it starts that's
towards the end all stars are
interconnected that's what I'm showing
there but essentially if you go away
from the Sun you should enter you should
go from the bird speak to the linear
regime
what is the bird speak well it's the
bird speak is that part of the Sun where
all the ropes are coming out they form a
bird speak as they go all the way to the
nearest star in this case Proxima
Centuri and as you approach Proxima
Centauri you also have a bird speak so
every star has to have a bird speak when
it's connected to any other star okay
but anyways all stars are interconnected
that's the enterprise trying to leave
the bird's beak it slows down as it goes
into the linear regime right when it
goes into that linear regime over there
Newtonian gravity is no longer in effect
now you go into this linear gravity or
non gravity or drifting gravity
whichever way you want to look at it
okay so that's that's the the first
point that I want to make that all stars
are interconnected and because they're
all interconnected the whole platform
called galaxy rotates as a carousel as a
bicycle wheel end of story
so how do they do it in general
relativity well on general relativity
they do it a little differently
see they do it more or less like jf g
showed here he showed these black holes
and you weighed down the canvas of
space-time the fabric of space-time and
things fall down the hole okay that's
how they do it and so it's
done completely with mass with a thing
called mass and what's the problem with
mass well the problem with mass is first
it's a there's no definition of the word
mass hey the general notion that people
have out there is that mass is how much
matter there is in something matter is
anything you can touch physically okay
Eric when science world of physics says
the quantity of matter continued in an
object it's right for words what you
learned in high school and the Wikipedia
has a couple definitions they're both in
the same way one made this thing was
conceptually between at least seven
different aspects of mass right and one
of those is that it's the amount of
matter in an object so they all agree
that it's the amount of matter they try
to give you the idea that mass is you
know you know where do they start with
this they say what is an object an
object is what it's made out of an
object is made out of atoms and this is
a similar idea they say look what is
mass mass is the quantity of matter in
an object if you count the ten thousand
let's say hydrogen atoms let's assume
that's the unit of mass for the sake of
argument so we have ten thousand atoms
in an in an object so that's the mass of
the object ten thousand atoms that's not
the way they phrase it they would say oh
that's got one kilogram of mass right
they wouldn't say it's ten thousand
atoms but why do they say that it's the
quantity of matter why do they point to
the ten thousand atoms because they say
an object is that which is comprised of
something and so that's where they tie
in mass with the object you're supposed
to think of mass as the object itself
has all those little components of the
object that's the issue but what happens
a black hole crushes all matter out of
existence there you have two references
one from professor Cole Miller
University of Maryland
one from David Harrison at the
University of Toronto and they both say
that matter inside a black hole is
crushed out of existence
so if mass is the quantity of matter and
black hole crushes all matter out of
existence we have a circular argument
because a black hole is only made of
mass that's all it's got in it
essentially and what is mass it's the
quantity of matter and what happens the
inside a black hole all matter is
crushed out of existence so what do we
have how can a black hole have mass if
you just crushed all matter out of
existence and mass is the quantity of
matter so we have a circular argument
and that's part of that's the second
problem I see you with like oh we have
no definition we don't know if it's an
object or a concept we don't know if
it's a hole or if it's a ball like ball
or a hole black balls a standalone
three-dimensional object that floats out
there in space hole is a little entrance
into the fabric of space-time I don't
know how you can visualize that that's
gonna be what I'm gonna be talking about
now so these two things are different
and then you have the issue of mass that
they say we're gonna do it with mass but
mass is a concept that's the first
problem
second mass is really undefined it's got
seven definitions because they could
never define it a couple of gurus John
Wheeler among them says that they don't
have a definition yet Oh for the word
mass nothing that they can really use
and then it turns out that you know even
if you define it as quantity of matter
we have a circular argument in in that
the black hole crushes all matter out of
existence if mass is the quantity of
matter and it all gets crushed out of
existence how can you have mass which is
supposedly what the black hole is going
to use to affect stars from a distance
it's going to use its great mass and I
had a little
little there's a fable that I created
the elephant and the turtle showed it
the other day but I'll show it one more
time because it's pertinent at this
point and that's that you know the
elephant suppose he tells everyone that
he can move the turtle around from a
distance without touching it and it
doesn't with its mass it doesn't do with
it it doesn't do it with an elongated
object it doesn't with mass and you say
well how does they do it with mass mass
is a concept well it turns out that you
know the turtle figure out because he
could see in the ultraviolet range that
the elephant was using a stick
to move him around but the stick had
gave out ultraviolet light and so you
know the elephant's couldn't see it but
the turtle good so the elephant was
really cheating was you know giving
Turtles and everybody else a bunch of
nonsense of a bunch of BS that it could
move you know objects from a distance
simply because of its great mass no such
thing you need to have a mechanism a
physical mechanism an elongated mediator
to do action at a distance and what they
want to do with the black hole is say
look we're not going to do it with with
objects we're just doing gonna do it
with this mathematical concept we're
gonna take mass right and simply because
we have lots of kilograms
that alone affects sings at a distance
and this is nonsense this is absolute
nonsense like saying that you're gonna
move a star around with love and you say
what do you mean you do it with love
yeah see because I have lots of love I
have tons of love and the more love I
have the more influence I have over that
star well how did you do that well the
way I did it see love pushes the canvas
the fabric of space-time downwards
and creates this you know this
depression and the wall of the
depression is curved so the start wants
to fall into the hole so it's attracted
to the hole the black hole kind of pulls
on there through this curved surface
that's what's happening and that's what
what the black hole theory is all about
you know pulling it like that what's the
problem with that theory let's go with
with what's wrong with that here you
have a three dimensional object turning
in space and suddenly it turns into a
two dimensional object you're going
through the hole and what are you going
into see the question here is what is
the surface now soon as you get into the
hole
what's the surface that's pointing
towards you what is in front of you
right now do we have space in other
words what's the hole facing there you
see we're not talking about a ball we're
talking about here we turn about three
dimensional object that suddenly turns
into a two-dimensional entrance -
whatever - whatever because you know you
cannot conceptualize this because it's
so realistic hey let me give you another
vision of what I'm trying to say here
here's yet another vision let's wait
till it stops I'll start it at the
beginning
and it starts about here right after
this here you have a two-dimensional
vision of a black hole okay they turn it
around they turn into a ball just to
show you that it's got an event horizon
then it goes back to the 2-dimensional
bond they show you the balls for the in
there what's pulling those balls
downwards why don't the balls fall
upwards into a black hole why don't they
show you this well this would be
counterintuitive people say well where
is it going up well the reason he goes
balls go down is because on earth here
things fall to the floor and so they
always like to talk about downwards they
never like to talk about things falling
upwards because that's counterintuitive
so they have this show where they say oh
the balls are falling downwards every
visit okay I understand that there's a
curved surface things fall downwards
well here you have a curved surface
why don't they fall upwards well because
gravity pulls it down words it's not the
curvature of space that pulls things
downwards because the only way they
would go downwards is if gravity pulls
them downwards otherwise if there's a
curve there's no reason for anything to
follow that curve downwards okay a curve
can also go upwards if if gravity is in
that direction what you've got to
identify is what gravity is what is
coming in contact with a little balls
that are going upwards or downwards like
in the first case there but the other
day issue so we got two issues one they
turned the two-dimensional hole okay
which is that one there and they turn it
into a ball they turn it into a ball
because they need the event horizon the
event horizon is a sphere that wrote
that and encapsulate the singularity at
the center of that ball but then they
turn this into a surrealistic scenario
where they have the the
you Larry at the bottom that's where all
the mass is concentrated supposedly and
the mass for whatever reason pulls space
down space-time downwards the canvas of
space-time it's pulled downwards why is
it pulled downwards well because on
earth we know that everything falls
downwards
if nothing falls upwards you know by
gravity at least and so what happens
because the mass the excessive mass of a
black hole pulls the canvas downwards it
creates a curve and then they say well
any object like a star whatever that's
near the curve just follows the
curvature of space-time down the
space-time downwards but it only goes
downward speaking only if gravity pulls
it down words otherwise there's no
reason for for that curvature to be
upwards if the if gravity if the source
of gravity were upwards then the
curvature you know would be in in the
upwards direction the balls would fall
upwards why don't they show this every
day so that people would say hold it I
got a problem
what do you mean the balls fall upwards
yeah because then you have to explain
the source of gravity and you can't just
say mass I thought mass pushed
everything downwards how come here I'm
showing that mass is pushing it upwards
okay so this this is the problem the
problem is that these people are trying
to get away with first a 3d to 2d to 3d
scenario they go back and forth between
the 2d and 3d and second they use the
word mass when mass has no physical no
physicality mass is a concept you can't
say mass does this or mass does that you
have to have a physical mechanism mass
is a mathematical concept so you cannot
say that mass pushed the you know the
canvas downwards the fabric of
space-time it curved of curved the
fabric of space-time and created a tea
freshen okay so you have to have
something come in physical contact with
a ball to explain gravity you can't say
that gravity does that because that's
what we're trying to explain gravity
you can't take gravity for for granted
and say oh I know what gravity is okay
so this is the issue that's that's where
we that's where the two of the problems
are the other issue that I want to talk
about I hope you understood that I don't
know if I should maybe clarify that one
more time you have the you have the the
sheet the the canvas of space-time and
unless you put any objects in there you
know it's a flat surface
supposedly flat now you put something in
there a star star has mass meaning it's
got some kind of weight it's got to be
affected by gravity and so it pushes it
down where it pushes the canvas
downwards what was 2-dimensional
suddenly becomes three-dimensional now
you have some death okay so you have a
third dimension which is height okay of
the black hole in this case right the
ball the the mass of that star right is
so big that it becomes a black hole and
and it just pushes the you know the
canvas of space-time so deep that any
star no matter how far away it is is
affected by it and those that are very
close to the hole are drawn in why are
they drawn in they're drawn in because
of the geometry of space-time the
geometry of the depression that's the
argument that Einstein had in 1915 1916
he says there's a curvature of
space-time caused by the mass but why
does the mass push it downwards
so that the curvature so that the ball
can roll down the curve we have to
figure out how mass a concept bent
space-time
mass is not a physical objects the
concepts so you can't say that mass did
it what's happening here is these people
are saying look there was a star it was
so big so humongous had so much mass
that the mass is what bends space-time
first air second their area is that
they're invoking Newton they're saying
there's a force it causes a force on
space I'm pushing the depression
downwards you know downwards anglers
downwards and we're so deep that it
bends space-time and now any object like
a star you know ball just rolls down or
tends to roll down this inclined plane
this this curvature why does it then go
upwards
why doesn't mass push upwards and have
the Sun go upwards you can't do that
because you need to establish the source
of the force that's bending the canvas
the fabric of space-time you need to
identify what is what is caught what LM
gated object is affecting the star you
can't see mass doesn't you can't see
mass bend space-time and that
mass-produces curvature and that mass
compels the star to go around itself or
to pull gases from its skin you can't
say any of those because mass is a
concept you have to identify the
physical object that's pushing to canvas
downwards that's causing the the
curvature of the depression you know you
know the canvas being curved of the
geometry of space-time being modified
and then yes you could explain why this
ball falls into the hole and again since
there's no direction in space out there
why does any go upwards or into your eye
or away from your eye why does it do it
sideways I got a little jiff to uh to
show you this is my fish tank analogy
okay here you have a fish tank and we're
gonna fill it up with water okay and
we're gonna turn it into space because
that's a three dimensional volume there
and space is more or less you got to
think of it as three dimensional volume
what these people are doing they're
putting black holes in there and the
black holes are sucking in matter and
going down deep into that cone but you
can see how third sir realistic this is
because they have a flat top each one of
these black holes if you look at them
they have a flat top and the question is
which way is the flat top facing you
have one facing down where's the other
one facing upwards the other one facing
towards the side what is that hole into
this is a surrealistic scenario when you
put a black hole a two-dimensional
scenario on to a three-dimensional
volume that's the that's the problem the
problem is that these people are
introducing here let me show you a black
hole and a little bigger so that you can
see here's the black hole you can see
it's got a flat top they're putting that
into that background which is supposed
to be a three dimensional volume so they
have a two dimensional flat surface with
a hole into it right and they're putting
this in a three dimensional volume which
is the volume of space now you could
even take a word yeah one more step and
say look it's a it's a four dimensional
space-time so we got a two dimensional
flat surface in a four dimensional
volume and you can picture that at all
so what's the problem the problem is
that you know these people are cheating
they're saying look you know we have
these this black hole and it's a it's
got a flat entrance because the hole can
only be in to a flat surface
like you know I just showed you Bugs
Bunny here see if I can find him again
was it this one it gets this one no
wrong one I'll get it here give me a
second here
is it this one no same one no no wrong
one
well I can't find it now it only got so
many of these is it this one no this is
J of Gees
unbelievable how I can lose these things
no wrong one I'm gonna have to try them
all until I get the right one
now here it is okay see you can see the
difference between a black hole and
between a hole in a ball and between a
black hole which is supposed to be a
two-dimensional entrance surrealistic
entrance into into space-time because
that's the one on the right if you see
the one on the right on the bottom right
it's a hole and it's treating space-time
as a flat surface as if you were at the
edge of space-time
okay it's if you were at the surface of
space-time not as if you're inside the
volume of space-time so the hole the
reason you can see the hole is because
there is nothing on this side of that
surface it's like you're outside of
space-time looking at a hole like you
would look at a hole in a Swiss cheese
you can see the hole why because you're
on the outside looking at the cheese and
you're looking at a hole going inside
the cheese because there's nothing on
this side of the cheese how do you see a
hole inside the cheese which is what
they're trying to illustrate and that's
what I'm showing here with a fishtank
analogy I'm saying you know here we have
a volume volume of water and that's
gonna turn into the volume of space okay
and they put a black hole in there a
cone a two-dimensional cone and the
surface of that hole is into the volume
I mean I can understand if the hole is
at the edge of this of the surface of
you know the surface of space-time
you cannot imagine that if it's inside
the volume that's the that's the problem
with this scenario but it doesn't stop
there there's another problem also with
it and it's like this here turns out
that gravitational waves coming out of a
black hole
you know they they're transverse waves
gravitational waves are transverse waves
but they are not dipole transverse waves
like most electromagnetic waves they are
quadrupole waves they simultaneously
squeeze and stretch matter in two
perpendicular directions so there's a
picture of it you see that the wave is
changing its shape it's squeezed first
in one direction and it's squeezed in
the other direction okay that's all
they're saying but the important part
here is that gravitational waves are
transverse waves keep that in mind
transverse waves is like the famous
transverse wave of light that they show
you in high school that's what a
transverse wave is transverse wave means
that the wave moves up and down
perpendicular to the direction of travel
of the wave as a whole
that's what a transverse wave is yeah
and so what's the problem the problem is
that is what I showed here earlier I
think it's this one look at the waves
that this again you're looking at the
surface of space-time there so the holes
are into space-time what's the black
stuff on top of but that gives shape to
that surface that's the first problem
okay but now look at the waves the waves
that are coming out of there those are
transverse waves are there ocean type
waves and ocean type waves really are a
mixture of longitudinal and transverse
waves they've got both of these okay but
sea ocean waves are surface waves again
keep in mind they're surface waves and
and and what these people are saying is
that you know the surface waves are
coming out of the volume the inside
volume of space-time they're not coming
out of the surface of space-time they're
coming out of the inside of the ocean
not at the surface of the ocean and
that's also the problem with
but Peter scenario had he had a surfing
and that's what I was trying to tell him
in the other day I don't think he
understood what I was saying to him he's
got a surface and he's talking about
what's happening to the little what is
it
oil drop here let me put it up there so
we have something to look at
he's saying look here we have it we have
the surface of the oil this is not the
inside of the oil it's on the surface
and you can only create these transfers
/ longitudinal ways because both
components are in those waves you can
only create them on the surface of the
oil okay you can't create this same
effect inside the volume of the oil you
can't create it inside like I'm showing
here with the where was it the tank the
fish tank I can find it you can't you
can't do it here inside the inside the
volume of the fish tank you can do it on
the surface of the fish tank you can't
create waves on the inside of the you
can't create transverse waves on the
inside of the tank
why because transverse waves only
propagate in solids you have to turn
space-time into a solid okay and here
you have it particles in transfers if
the particles in transverse waves move
perpendicularly to the direction of
propagation so it cannot propagate in a
gas or a liquid
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah you can read
the rest of that transfers wave need a
rigid medium okay you can't do it in
water you have to do it in solids like
steel that's why I had that statement
from this fella who said you know that
[Music]
that space-time is billions and billions
and billions of space he was saying
billions and billions and billions times
stiffer than steel makes no sense
whatsoever these people have turned
space not only into a physical object
but into a an object that is stiffer
than steel and you wonder how does the
poor astronauts manage to get through
the steel in their mansion him if all of
a space were a solid bar of steel how
does the astronaut out there and not
even get his you know
elbow scratched with all this steel
that's the issue these people are
totally irrational they're idiots
they're any they've turned face into a
physical object and into a an object
that's stiffer than steel and they had
to do that for the transverse ways so
when these people from LIGO say that
they detected waves okay from the
collision of two black holes I don't
know how they collided through all that
steel but let's assume they collided the
waves that this thing generated this
collision generated those waves are
transverse waves transverse waves can
only propagate in steel in solids they
don't transfer they cannot transfer
through water liquid they cannot
transfer through gases and so these
people had to take the next step and
assume that space is a physical object
not only a physical object made of
particles as we know from quantum but
it's it's stronger than steel stiffer
than steel because that's the only way
you can transfer transverse waves all
the way to earth
and detective and so what's the problem
Peter scenario well peter scenario is
that he's got these he uses it an
analogy for stuff in in quantum right
and see if I can find this again he uses
it here to show his water droplet but
that's a surface phenomenon first second
he's doing it in liquid he can't
simulate anything related to quantum
because quantum works with transverse
waves transfers waves only propagate in
solids and second you got to show this
scenario
now that the surface that's easy show me
that same thing inside the volume of the
oil first and second how can you do it
in oil if it's going to create if it's
supposed to create transverse waves and
transverse waves can only be propagated
through solid objects so he's got too
many problems with this scenario this
scenario is worthless it's a nice
experiment people like to watch fancy
things saying hey let me show you
something some fancy stuff look I can
show you how these drops bounce and go
around and they love to watch all these
things they're fascinated by all these
experiments but what they'll never be
able to do is explain the cause the
mechanism that's that's when they go
they describe it mathematically they say
look the wave does this and there's this
potential and we have a probability
distribution and bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla and never will they tell you let me
tell you what the mechanism let let me
tell you how Mother Nature does this
thing what the magic is they'll never be
able to tell you that and they never
even touch the subject because they
always think that a description is the
same thing as an explanation they think
that description is a mechanism and they
say yeah I've explained it I've told you
the mechanism see here's the equation
that's what they tell you so if you if
you're waiting for for an explanation if
you're waiting to understand the
mechanism well you got a long wait
believe me you'll be traveling through
time okay
so here's another statement this one
from the stock exchange that transfers
waves are shear waves whose particle
particles move perpendicular to their
direction of propagation that's known as
a transverse wave right they can
propagate through solids solids should
be there now because solids have enough
shear strength the shear strength is one
of the forces that hold up solid
together and prevent it from falling
apart that doesn't happen in liquids
liquids the case with liquids is that
liquids do not have that much shear
strength for example consider this
if you take a glass of water and
suddenly somehow you remove the glass
the water will not keep its shape and
will just flow away so in fact it just
boils down to the fact that transverse
waves need a medium rigid enough to
propagate which liquids can't provide so
you cannot use liquids to do anything in
quantum anything because quantum deals
with transverse waves at the invisible
level at the subatomic level it's all
transverse waves so if you cannot
produce transverse waves because you put
liquid in there you say well there's
this fluid ether whatever that's flowing
no it's got to be rigid like a piece of
stone then you can door steel right then
you can talk about transverse waves then
you can make your case but then that
means the atom is trapped in a box of
Steel and I was trying to tell that to
Peter the other day that you know he's
taking this 2d scenario and in but when
we talk about the atom and anything
going around the atom we're talking
about a volume we're talking about 3d
scenario so how does he extrapolate his
2d analogy to the 3d scenario he can't
and he never will because it's so
realistic it's uh you know and it's it's
nonsense to say that you can put a 2d
black hole into a 3d universe 3d space
and that's when they slightly you know
they they'd have this slave hand they
say look I'm gonna put the ball in the
in the volume I'm gonna put the ball in
space but let me explain it to you well
what what it does well what the ball
does is curved space-time what do you
mean in curved space-time yeah I curse
space I mean all the things fall into
the hole what do you mean oh where in
what direction is the hole let me show
you and they point to the 2d scenario
now they suddenly switch on you and go
to the - 2 dimensional scenario and they
show you you know the curve they say see
the depression is caused by mass and the
star
this ball this whatever over here falls
inside the hole so they keep going into
two from 2d to 3d to 2d if they talk
about you know the if they're gonna talk
about the event horizon they have to put
a ball in there they have to put a 3d
ball in space right so here's this black
ball in black space right and they say
well here's here's this ball and this is
what this massive star became a ball but
then you can't understand why it's
attracting things they say well what it
does the ball weighs down space-time and
now they go to the 2d scenario and they
show you the curvature of space-time
they say see the Sun falls inside the
hole what hole the hole created by the
ball that pressed down on space-time and
turns out there is no ball to begin with
it's just a singularity which is zero
dimensional lots of mass no body no
structure no matter what is mass it's
the quantity of matter it's been crushed
out of existence we have nothing that
nothing curved space-time it did it
downwards it didn't do upwards why did
it do it downwards because it needed
Newtonian gravity and force the word
force not no longer the curvature of
space-time but force so it's all the
mass the whole thing is irrational is
nonsense I hope you followed proof
because there's many aspects to this
okay anyways we're about the end of time
I've got a couple more things here the
first one is that you got to distinguish
between wave and current okay wave is up
and down movement in the cert on the
surface of the water it's a 2d scenario
current is what moves through the body
of the ocean okay it's the movement of
water under the ocean it's under water
currents that's what a current is and
[Music]
here I have a little picture of it so
that people understand the difference
between waves and currents and should
not mix them wave is what's on the
surface of an ocean current is what goes
out where the fishies are right
underneath you know is somewhere in the
body of the ocean so you should not
confuse current with ways if you're
gonna talk about the scenario of black
hole being a three-dimensional ball
inside the volume of space treat the
three dimensional space or four
dimensional space-time whichever you
have to talk about currents and not
about waves is certainly you cannot talk
about transverse waves if if space or
space-time is a fluid or a gas space or
space-time have to be made of steel or
stronger than steel they have to be made
of a single piece almost right they have
to be stronger than steel stiffer than
steel in order to convey or propagate
transverse waves okay that's why they
had to make it you know that's why they
talk about space being billions of times
stiffer than steel and and here I have
another difference for for just so you
know the difference between
longitudinal and transverse waves
earthquakes they produce both through
the earth and the funny part is that
longitudinal waves travel 1.7 times
faster than sheer transverse waves and
so you know again the now G that I've
got is that if this if this is the case
that longitudinal waves train them
travel faster if this is the case then
if you extrapolate this that means you
should hear the thunder before you see
the lightning flash in other words sound
should travel faster than
then light if light is comprised of
transverse waves because longitudinal
waves such as sound travel faster than
transverse waves so you can't say that
light is a transverse wave or that
anything in quantum mechanics is a
transverse wave because it would be as
slow as hell and that takes me to my
last shift there which I've shown into
past but I'll put it one more time for
those newbies you can see that the
transverse wave is a snail goes very
slowly turtle beats the hell out of it
and 1.7 times faster turtle is the
longitudinal waves like sound and the
cheetah is the torsion wave it's
mediated by web it's mediated by a rope
torsion on a rope that kind of wave that
that disturbance travels millions of
times faster on a longitudinal wave
which try and travels faster than a
transverse wave so light or gravity if
they're made out of transverse waves
they should be as slow as you know you
should beat them by running anybody can
beat a transverse wave it's easy they're
slow so you can't use transverse waves
for anything in quantum and if st to
simulate light or gravity and then with
that we end the show today so those were
the problems with with the black hole's
ideas and the surface waves that were
presented the other day both by jfg that
showed this 2d scenario and the whole
you know pointing upwards but they never
identified the medium that's upwards
here why because that should be the
surface of space-time that's the end of
space-time that's where space-time ends
you're at the surface of space and then
you can see the hole and then the
question is well what's on that side
what's on the other side of the Swiss
cheese I can see the Swiss cheese on
this side I got air that's in the case
of the Swiss cheese okay now let's look
at the space-time space-time has
hole in it at the surface what's on this
side of it you see you can't introduce
that that scenario in the middle in the
volume of space-time you can only do it
at the surface those are the arguments
so keep that in mind whenever you
discuss against a mathematical physicist
we'll see you next time on Sunday and
hopefully I can get back to where I was
on at the point and I'm gonna continue
with that next time unless well I might
do a a recap of what I said today so
keep that in mind was he you then next
Sunday bye bye